[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle agriculture alimentation
écologique mais aussi politique autour
d'un plat et d'un dessert qui est choisi
par notre invité et cette semaine nous
recevons Guillaume kasbariian bonjour
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci et avec moi pour
présenter cette émission Jean-Pierre
Montanez ça va Jean-Pierre
vous êtes député d'Eure-et-Loir depuis
2017 et depuis un an président de la
commission des affaires économiques de
l'Assemblée logique pour celui qui a
fait ses classes prépa dans la
prestigieuse école Saint Louis de
Gonzague avant d'intégrer les secs vous
défendez le droit à la propriété le
libre-échange et vous souhaitez la
réintroduction des néonicotinoïdes pour
sauver la filière de la betterave
sucrière en vin vous avez récemment
porté une proposition de loi anti-squate
alors c'est un peu surprenant parce que
vous êtes né à Marseille vous avez vécu
dans le sud à à Aix-en-Provence à
Pélissanne puis au Kenya avant
d'atterrir en Eure-et-Loir et pour le
menu du jour vous nous emmenez squatter
en en vrac alors là il faut reconnaître
que c'est un peu l'hôpital qui se fout
de la charité n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre
exactement avec de l'aligot et de la
saucisse et en dessert des fruits de
saison et français abricots fraises et
framboise dans le dessous des plats les
agriculteurs transforment et vantent à
la ferme le local et le circuit court on
la cote dans les pieds dans le plat on
marche sur la tête un des plats qui
pourrissent des fruits qui pourrissent
dans les champs faute de main d'oeuvre
reportage à suivre
on passe à table tout de suite cuisine
et confidence
[Musique]
Guillaume casbarion votre bio est un
atlas l'Arménie terre natale de vos
arrières grands-parents le Liban terre
d'accueil de la famille de votre Mère la
France et Marseille où se réfugient
celle de votre père et où vous naissez
sans parler du Kenya Brigitte l'a dit
vous avez vécu 3 ans naïvement je me
disais que le plat du jour
s'expliquerait par cette géographie avec
Brigitte on imaginait se régaler d'un
chat warma libanais dans sa voieuse
pitta ou encore d'un Yama Shoma exotique
plaquénion de chèvre grillées de Panisse
marseillais ces bâtons frits à la farine
de pois chiches on espère aussi
secrètement découvrir le sous Berek
totem de la cuisine arménienne
littéralement un gâteau de fromage non
rien de tout ça enfin presque puisque le
fromage semble être votre passion comme
l'art du contre-pied car dans cette
Atlas il nous manque une carte celle de
l'Auvergne là où visiblement le coup de
foudre culinaire a frappé au point de
vous faire oublier vos racines un
parfait amour filet donc avec l'aligot
que vous avez demandé tout ça mérite un
éclaircissement pourquoi le vert c'est
vrai que j'aurais pu vous demander un
plat libanais ou un plat arménien le
soubologue est probablement mon plat
arménien préféré ma grand-mère avait
l'habitude de le faire ça prend
plusieurs heures pour le faire
je me suis dit que vous auriez du mal à
faire un bon soupe de leg et je me suis
dit aussi on aurait trouvé à Paris il y
a forcément une table effectivement que
comme j'aime le fromage comme j'aime les
plats gourmands comme j'aime l'Auvergne
comme j'aime la France et le terroir je
me suis dit un plat emblématique que
j'aime bien manger hiver comme été la
Ligue au saucisse
j'aime bien quand les chasseurs parfois
me ramènent du gibier cuisiner du gibier
j'aime bien les plats en sauce j'aime
bien cuisiner aussi quand j'en ai un
petit peu le temps et la LIGO ceci pour
moi c'est un peu le le symbole du plat
de terroir que beaucoup de Français
aiment bien qu'on vous sert parfois
aussi d'ailleurs dans cette fête du
village y compris en Eure-et-Loir ça
peut arriver ça peut arriver vous avez
des camions c'est un truc en Auvergne
quand même pour vous tombiez amoureux de
ce plat non je pense que vraiment c'est
l'amour du fromage et tout du plat de
terroir après c'est un plat qui est
aussi à la fois qui parait simple comme
ça certains peuvent dire oui c'est quand
même assez simple c'est des pommes de
terre de la crème du beurre avec de la
tomme fraîche de l'Aubrac mais en fait
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est-à-dire que avant que ça réussisse
à filer il y a tout un savoir-faire le
bon aligot ça se fait pas comme ça et
donc c'est
vraiment le tour de main mais vraiment
il faut mieux l'acheter auprès de
spécialistes de vaut mieux aller dans un
bureau d'ailleurs sur place pour pouvoir
en déguster j'ai pas la prétention de
bien faire la Ligue vous l'avez raté
plusieurs fois je vais être honnête avec
vous mais c'est quand même un plat qui
est très sympa qui conviviale aussi
parce qu'il y a une notion de partage à
table et c'est quelque chose que on aime
bien voilà on aime bien se servir à
arriver avec le plat au milieu se dire
on sert de l'aligot on sert de la
saucisse et je suis un bon vivant je
suis gourmand j'aime le fromage donc je
me suis dit bah oui elle négocies
pourquoi pas alors on va le goûter
ensemble
il est très bon très bien réussi
cette aligot comme il est un peu froid
je pense qu'il a du mal à filer mais
c'est quand même très très bon mais le
goût est là vraiment on ressent le goût
très vite un Brigitte un plat qui
remontait au 12e siècle un la légende
raconte que sur la route de Saint-Jean
Saint-Jacques-de-Compostelle les moines
du Lanester d'Aubrac donnés au pèlerin
affamé un mélange de fromage et de
pommes de terre les pèlerins en fait ils
demandaient en latin quelque chose à
manger ce qui se disait à liquid c'est
devenu aligot pour le préparer il faut
écraser donc des pommes de terre à chair
farineuses Binch César Manon marabel
cuite à l'eau puis mélangez cette purée
avec de la crème vous l'avez dit et de
la tomme du Cantal fraîche râpée en
copeaux 3 c'est là où intervient le
petit secret car un bon aligot c'est
bien sûr le coup de main vigoureux pour
bien mélanger le fromage et parvenir à
cette texture onctueuse et en même temps
élastique alors l'aligot doit filer
comme on dit le secret utilisé un fouet
d'aligot une grande spatule en bois et
après il faut de l'huile de coude pour
bien filer l'aligot et vous vous êtes
équipés à la maison vous avez un petit
peu de matériel du fouet magique en
revanche j'ai j'ai quelques ustensiles
qui permettent d'essayer mais encore une
fois je fais confiance aux
professionnels et à ceux qui le font
bien donc celui-là est bon il a du mal à
filer mais il est très bon et donc voilà
mais c'est vrai que c'est un plaisir de
cuisiner de temps en temps qu'on a le
temps c'est pas toujours le cas parce
que la politique ça prend beaucoup de
temps et à l'Assemblée et en
circonscription mais enfin quand il y a
quelques instants moi ça me détend et à
chaque fois j'essaye de faire soit des
plats un peu traditionnels un peu
gourmands que j'aime bien français
plutôt bien j'aime bien faire les civets
de de biche j'aime bien faire ensuite
des plats Arméniens je vous disais le
sous-bolek j'ai tendance à le à essayer
de le faire j'essaye de reprendre la
recette de ma grand-mère et de de mener
à bien c'est pas évident parce qu'il
faut un bon trois heures pour réussir à
vous pouvez nous expliquer en deux mots
j'allais dire pour simplifier c'est une
sorte de lasagnes arménienne sur lequel
vous avez des pâtes qui sont des vrais
enfin qui ressemble à des pâtes à
lasagnes vous avez plusieurs couches et
entre chaque couche vous mettez du
fromage qui est donc de la feta de
l'emmental et du persil entre chaque
coup je vous mettais un petit peu de
beurre aussi il rajoute un côté gourmand
une fois que vous avez fini de monter en
fait cet étalage de pâte et de fromage
comme des lasagnes vous le mettez au
four et là ça
dortine non non c'est là où il y a pas
de viande même si j'adore la viande et
je mange beaucoup de viande mais mais
c'est un très très bon plat et c'est un
plat familial que les Arméniens
connaissent bien et alors il y a un
débat parce que vous dites à lasagne
comme une vraie pâte de pâte on en parle
à l'intérieur des pâtes filo pâte à
brique c'est quand on a un peu la flemme
et là c'est du bug avec du coup c'est
pas du tout Bolex c'est du Bullet à ce
moment-là et et c'est un peu plus je
trouve que c'est un peu plus sec le fait
de d'avoir le sous-bolek est beaucoup
plus onctueux parce qu'il y a un côté un
peu plus pâteux un peu plus là qu'on
parle de gâteau aussi mais le bulleg pas
de philo est souvent un petit peu sec
mais on le sert à l'apéro de temps en
temps ça peut arriver mais enfin voilà
la cuisine ça permet de voyager aussi
vous pariez tout à l'heure des voyages
moi j'adore le terroir français j'adore
les régions de France et j'adore la
bonne bouffe française j'ai été baigné
dans ça depuis que je suis tout petit un
peu partout j'ai aussi mes racines et je
les oublie pas avec mes mon histoire
familiale avec ce qui me reste de ma
famille alors par exemple du
[Rires]
j'ai toujours eu la flemme pardon sur la
question du mot c'est plutôt fait
confiance soit ta mère soit en lâchement
mais c'est vrai que c'est tout à fait
possible de faire je crois que c'est
pour pois chiche après vous avez de la
crème de sésame à faire du tajine
exactement
avec le Thermomix éventuellement et puis
vous rajoutez du citron je l'ai déjà
fait mais je trouvais que le résultat
était moins bon que ma mère donc
votre maman est une excellente
cuisinière c'est celle qui vous a
inspiré ma grand-mère elle était aussi
donc on aime bien la on aime bien donc
vous vous brisez un petit peu les hommes
dans la famille ont toujours aimé aussi
cuisiner et déguster aussi c'est vrai
donc non c'est juste qu'on aime bien
ouais mais le enfin le repas pour moi
c'est un moment à la fois familial tous
les Français se réunissent à table et
c'est pas juste un moment utilitaire on
est là pour s'alimenter et prendre des
nutriments l'alimentation
et la table française c'est aussi un art
de vivre c'est aussi l'art à la
française c'est aussi une marque de
fabrique c'est ce qui fait vivre aussi
l'image de la France dans le monde faut
pas l'oublier c'est de la richesse des
territoires et des terroirs c'est des
saveurs qui sont diversité assez
incroyable et je pense qu'on a le
meilleur bouffe du monde mais ce plaisir
on en parle souvent à table ici ce
plaisir de plus en plus contraint pas de
viande pas tant de trucs pas on commence
à être bordé quoi maintenant
je suis gourmand et je l'assume et je le
revendique après bien sûr il faut faire
attention à pas manger n'importe quoi
vous nous direz pas que vous mangez de
la viande tous les jours vous nous le
direz pas ça peut-être pas tous les
jours mais j'en mange plusieurs fois par
semaine est-ce que c'est bien ou pas
bien j'en sais rien mais j'aime ça
particulièrement votre alimentation avec
tout ce qu'on peut entendre pas devenir
citoyen non non mais par contre c'est
enfin il faut prendre le temps par
contre de manger c'est à dire ce qui est
le plus compliqué quand on a beaucoup de
travail quand les Français sont au
boulot c'est compliqué de réussir à bien
manger prendre le temps de soi de
cuisiner de prendre des produits frais
donc c'est ça peut-être l'enjeu c'est
aussi de se dire j'essaye d'éviter il
faut éviter la malbouffe
au mieux si on arrive au maximum mais
j'aime bien dans mon territoire en
Eure-et-Loir il y a beaucoup de marché
fermiers j'essaye autant que je peux de
prendre des produits frais de saison
tout à l'heure on parlera de la salade
de fruits mais aussi pour les légumes
c'est la même chose
donc on a moyen d'avoir une bonne
alimentation locale fraîche de qualité
du conventionnel j'ai aussi des acteurs
en conventionnel qui font de la
conservation des sols qui est une
technique qui permet d'éviter l'érosion
et qui permet de préserver la terre et
les vers de terre donc c'est je n'oppose
pas les modèles agricoles entre eux on a
la chance d'avoir une diversité des
modèles agricoles et moi je suis pas en
train de dire aux agriculteurs qu'il
faut qu'il fasse tous du bio ou tu tous
de du conventionnel ils sont c'est eux
les spécialistes et d'ailleurs ils ont
une vraie richesse de territoire et donc
il y a plusieurs modèles agricoles le
bio c'est très bien le conventionnel ça
peut être très bien aussi d'ailleurs on
a besoin d'avoir aussi des installations
conventionnelles classiques productive
intensive qui exporte parce qu'il faut
pas l'oublier si on arrive à avoir une
agriculture qui fonctionne c'est parce
qu'on est une un grand territoire
agricole qui a aussi de l'exportation
j'ai un territoire on produit beaucoup
de céréales c'est les grandes cultures
donc c'est important d'avoir une
agriculture qui se porte bien et qui est
capable d'exporter le jour où vous êtes
replié on a besoin de pesticides encore
pour avoir cette suffisamment pour
produire suffisamment les pesticides
vous savez que déjà les agriculteurs
sont engagés dans des plans de réduction
Phyto qui sont importants et puis ils
investissent aussi sur des technologies
qui permettent de limiter l'apport
d'azote aux produits phyto ça coûte très
cher pour voir le financer il faut que
vous ayez de grosses exploitations et
vous soyez en capacité de payer ces
machines qui vous permettent
d'économiser des produits chimiques il
le font et ils le font vraiment très
bien moi ce que je dis par contre sur
les produits phytos c'est qu'il faut pas
mettre des contraintes aux agriculteurs
que nous serions les seuls à mettre en
France à nos agriculteurs français dire
que si nos voisins
on est dans un marché unique européen et
c'est une force et moi je suis ravi
qu'on soit dans un marché unique
européen oui dans le même marché ça nous
donne une force incroyable et si on veut
avoir un marché économique européen qui
est qui est unifié faut qu'on ait les
mêmes règles et donc on peut pas dire à
nos agriculteurs alors vous je vais vous
enlever tel produit tel produit tel
produit tel produit vous allez être les
seuls d'Europe à avoir ces interdictions
là tous vos voisins vont pouvoir faire
par contre l'inverse en plus avec un
modèle économique plus rentable et
derrière tant pis pour vous ça marche
pas débrouillez-vous ça les agriculteurs
ils le vivent mal moi je le vis mal et
je me bats contre ce qu'on appelle des
surtranspositions c'est à dire parfois
la volonté en France d'interdire des
choses qui ont par contre autorisé
ailleurs donc s'il y a quelque chose à
interdit
bien sûr vous vous êtes battus pour
soirée introduit pour sauver la liberté
dans d'autres pays mais ce qui s'est
passé sur une unique continuides c'est
qu'on est arrivé à un moment sur la
betterave et j'ai une betteravier chez
moi je suis pas le seul avec un puceron
qui piquait la betterave et qui donnait
une jaunisse et qui du coup atrophiée
complètement la betterave qui marchait
plus quoi et il y avait pas de solution
alternative il y avait juste pas de
solution alternative et si vous n'avez
pas de betteraves vous avez pas non plus
de sucrerie parce que du coup c'est la
betterave qui vous permet de produire le
sucre et donc on s'est retrouvé il y a
quelques années dans une situation où
les agriculteurs disaient on peut plus
utiliser les néonicotinoïdes on n'a pas
de solution technique si vous nous aidez
pas en fait on va juste arrêter de
planter des betteraves on plantera autre
chose vous n'aurez plus de betteraves
donc vous n'aurez plus de sucreries et
ça s'arrêtera pendant que tous nos
voisins européens eux continuent à faire
autrement et c'est là où vous posez la
question qui m'attendez je connais pas
en train de se tirer une balle dans le
pied tirer une balle dans le pied de nos
agriculteurs
des hommes politiques qui font des
speechs des discours sur la souveraineté
alimentaire etc moi je suis moi je suis
sur la souveraineté alimentaire mais on
peut pas faire des speechs souveraineté
alimentaire et en même temps mettre des
contrats à nos agriculteurs qui seraient
les seuls à poser dans le marché
européen et ensuite se donner bonne
conscience ça marche pas si on est pour
la souveraineté alimentaire si on est
pour l'agriculture on doit aider les
agriculteurs dans la réduction bien sûr
de l'usage des phytos mais on ne peut
pas leur mettre des règles que nous
serions les seuls à leur poser en Europe
et dans le monde ça serait ridicule ça
ne fonctionnerait pas c'est ça que
j'essaye de dire faut que l'État aide
aussi pour la recherche mais c'est ce
qu'on a fait il y a eu des énormément
d'efforts qui ont été mis sur la
recherche sur les betteraves sur les
néonicotinoïdes et donc on a essayé de
trouver des alternatives mais ça prend
du temps il suffit pas de claquer des
doigts pour trouver une alternative à un
produit qui existait jusqu'à présent
mais ce débat là sur les néonic on l'a
eu récemment avec les fausses fines
puisqu'on avait décidé l'agence lancès
avait décidé d'interdire les fausses
fines ce qui pose un problème sur
l'export des céréales et on l'a encore
on était les seuls à se poser la
question des fossiles alors que tout les
pays autour des fausses fines pour
l'exportation les pays d'accueil de nos
céréales demandaient eux-mêmes
l'utilisation de la Faustine Faustine
pour des raisons sanitaires donc vous
voyez qu'à un moment on prend des
décisions absurdes quand je dis 11 et
parfois certaines agences ou parfois
certains politiques mais ces décisions
là elles sont complètement
contradictoires avec la volonté
politique qui est pour le coup me semble
assez partagé de souveraineté
alimentaire et de grandeur de
l'agriculture française est-ce qu'il
faut pas qu'il y ait pays qui donnent
l'exemple et qui disent bah voilà il
faut il faut être leader il faut être
pionnier dans cette démarche là parce
que si on se regarde en Chine failli
faïence avec les autres il y a une chute
l'immobilisme et la France doit
peut-être donner l'exemple et les autres
suivons derrière la France doit être la
meilleure écoute mais c'est vertueux oui
mais ça n'est pas vous ne serez pas le
meilleur en mettant les agriculteurs
dans une impasse où vous interdisez tout
et oui ils n'ont pas de solution là vous
serez pas le meilleur vous serez juste
plus larionnais vous serez plus là ils
arrêt reproduire mais la réalité si vous
devez commencer qui doit donner
l'exemple si je le redis si vous dites
aux agriculteurs bon vous êtes face à
une maladie qui touche vos reproduction
il n'y a pas de solution technique à
part un produit et que vous décidez
d'interdire ce produit la mécanique fait
que les agriculteurs qui sont quand même
dans un dans une économie libre on vous
diront bah écoutez moi je vais planter
autre chose et après d'ailleurs si ce
qui reste ça serait percute sur la
filière industrielle du coup vos
sucreries elles vont dire bah nous on a
plus de betteraves on va faire du sucre
par exemple au glyphosate on sait qu'il
y a un coup près qui va tomber à un
moment ou un autre ça a été prolongé
prolongé est-ce qu'on fait suffisamment
de recherche aujourd'hui pour être prêt
le jour où vraiment l'Union européenne
décidera que c'est interdit que on peut
pas avoir de dérogation est-ce que on
sera suffisamment prêt pour avoir des
un dérivatif pour pouvoir continuer à
produire comme on le fait aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'on sera prêt un jour à se
passer des produits phytos c'est un
ambition qu'on peut partager mais il ne
suffit pas d'interdire pour que tout
d'un coup par magie la solution arrive
c'est tout ce que j'essaie de dire donc
sur la glyphosate c'est un désherbant
qui permet aux agriculteurs notamment en
grande culture sur les céréales sur le
pain que nous mangeons que nous avons à
table de d'avoir donc des céréales et
d’éviter d'avoir des mauvaises herbes
qui poussent il y a d'autres techniques
qui peuvent exister mais qui sont un peu
plus mécaniques sur lesquels il faut
passer le tracteur un peu plus souvent
et il y a aussi une question autour de
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
qui est une technique respectueuse des
terres sur lesquelles on ne remue pas la
terre justement pour la laisser poser et
laisser la biodiversité dans le sol le
problème c'est que cette technique de
conservation des sols si vous n'avez pas
de glyphosate elle est morte parce que
du coup vous pouvez pas mécaniquement
enlever les mauvaises herbes vous pouvez
pas retourner le sol et vous avez plus
le produit qui vous permet d'enlever les
mauvaises herbes donc attention là
encore à ne pas nous mettre une
interdiction où on n'aurait pas de
solution alternative et moi si c'est
pour ensuite manger du blé qui vient de
milliers de kilomètres en dehors de
l'Union Européenne ça m'intéresse pas
donc moi j'aimerais bien qu'on garde
notre souveraineté nos agriculteurs nos
grandes cultures et qu'on soit sûr que
si on met une interdiction elle se passe
d'ailleurs pas au niveau franco-français
mais qu'elle se décide européen ça c'est
la bonne échelle pour interdire les
choses et faire avancer c'est qu'on est
dans un marché un donc les règles elle
va être le même pour toutes les acteurs
du marché unique c'est assez simple
comme fonctionnement sinon c'est qu'il y
a plus de marché unique et il y a de la
concurrence des loyales et ça ça marche
pas donc moi qui suis un Européen
convaincu un amoureux de ce marché
unique un amoureux aussi de des
relations internationales moi je
considère qu'il faut que la concurrence
elle soit loyale et on peut être très
ambitieux sur la transition écologique
et la réduction des usages de produits
phytos en investissant en trouvant des
solutions en mettant de la R&D au
maximum mais attention ce que je dis
c'est attention à ne pas mettre dans une
impasse technique de agriculteurs parce
qu'on a la chance d'avoir une
agriculture qui est forte et je ne
voudrais pas que dans les années qui
viennent on sent morde les doigts parce
qu'on aurait voté des interdictions on
aurait coupé complètement les solutions
agriculteurs et qu'on se retrouve à
importer tout ce qu'on est en train de
manger nos saucisses notre aligots notre
bain et tout le reste donc c'est ce que
j'essaye de dire c'est
respectons nos agriculteurs soyons
derrière eux et ils s'en prennent vous
savez plein la tête parce que dans ces
déballages à chaque fois sur les
néonicotinites que vous avez citées sur
le glyphosate il s'en prennent plein la
tête et je pense que la grille bashing
c'est une réalité dans notre pays
regardez les certains extrémistes un
camp qui aujourd'hui vient de lacérer
des serres ou qui viennent la serrer des
exploitations moi je condamne
systématiquement et j'entends un soutien
bien sûr mais c'est scandaleux ce que je
dis c'est que c'est des dalles voilà
c'est j'appelle pas ça autrement quand
vous allez sur la propriété d'autrui que
vous la serrez une serre que vous
détruisez une parcelle et que vous
faites semblant de planter des graines
de sarrasin machin enfin je veux dire là
on est dans le ridicule absolu mais on
est dans la délinquance voilà et donc la
loi elle doit s'appliquer avec fermeté
alors on va passer à ce vin que vous
avez apporté que vous avez choisi c'est
un un vin de la région de Bourgogne on
est dans la vallée de Lyon c'est un
iranci donc c'est une AOC ça a 15 km à
peu près d'Auxerre on est évidemment
avec du pinot noir et alors j'ai vu
qu'elle iranci il y avait aussi jusqu'à
10% de César c'est un cépage
traditionnel que moi je connaissais pas
qui est très local et visiblement un
petit peu un petit peu rustique on est
sur un millésime 2022 et la
particularité de l'iranie c'est pour ça
que vous l'avez choisi j'imagine c'est
qu'il y a des arômes de fruits rouges on
va retrouver ça aussi dans le dans le
dessert tout à l'heure donc du cassis de
la cerise de la griotte c'était très
aromatique mais en même temps
des tas d'impuissant mais qui se fonde
bien et c'est vraiment le vin que vous
avez choisi c'est un vin que vous
appréciez particulièrement pour ces
raisons là alors vous avez fait une très
belle description de lire aussi et
d'abord gagne moi j'aime bien les vans
Bourgogne parce que il y a une finesse
dans le Bourgogne qui est assez
appréciable le Pinot Noir est quand même
très agréable vous dites ça se marie
bien avec beaucoup de choses
et il se trouve qu'en Bourgogne il
existe des appellations qui restent
accessibles parce que vous savez qu'il y
a aussi une question de prix il y a
quelques appellations en Bourgogne où
les prix sont devenus très très élevés
et donc c'est dommage parce que pour les
bonnes tables populaires françaises on
en a un petit peu moins mais cela dit
reste des appellations dans le nord de
la Bourgogne mais aussi dans le sud dans
le Mâconnais etc sur lequel vous avez
des appellations qui restent accessibles
et iranci je trouve que c'est un bon
rapport qualité finalement c'est un bon
rapport qualité-prix pour du bourgogne
code de serre c'est la même chose et
donc vous avez enfin ces mêmes choses
vous avez aussi le même les mêmes
caractéristiques et donc ça fait partie
des bourgognes plaisir
sur lequel vous arrivez à avoir des
bouteilles qui sont très agréables à des
prix qui restent accessibles pour un bon
repas du dimanche en famille ça le fait
bien et ça se marie avec beaucoup de
choses
avec modération surtout on va voir à
présent si vous êtes incollable c'est le
quiz
alors on va parler de ce fameux houmous
je sais pas comment vous dites Ramos
Ramos plat culte de cette cuisine du
Moyen-Orient et au cœur d'une guerre en
paternité entre le Liban Israël
sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses les
premières recettes de purée de pois
chiches apparaissent dans des traités
arabes de cuisine il y a près de 2000
ans
ça me paraît pas impossible ça doit être
assez ancien je dirais que c'est
possible alors le pois chiche est très
ancien la purée de pois chiches et très
ancienne mais pas à ce point là c'était
au 10e siècle
arabes de cuisine peut-être qu'avant
elle existait le houmous tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui aurait été inventé
pour l'élite turque au 18e siècle à
Damas voir à Beyrouth
s
vous diront que c'est arménien aussi le
houmous les Grecs aussi les chipriotes
revendique la paternité du houmous donc
là franchement vous mettez en difficulté
vrai là encore
[Musique]
le revendiquent aussi mais là ça serait
la version officielle à l'instar de la
fête à grecque le houmous Libanais est
protégé par une AOP depuis 2008
ça me surprendrait parce que j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde peut
produire du homos donc ça me
surprendrait qu'il est le même niveau de
protection que je dirais plutôt faux oui
faut il y a eu il y a pas une demande
qui a été faite par les Libanais mais
elle a été refusée enfin le record du
plus grand houmous homologué par le
Guinness Book et de 10450 de kilos
réalisés en 2010 par des cuisinés
israéliens bref
ça me paraît pas impossible donc j'irai
alors c'est vrai sur la quantité mais
c'est faux parce que c'est des
cuisiniers libanais
plat mais là aussi c'est un plaisir pour
l'apéro
et c'est marrant ça fait voyager là
aussi parce que beaucoup revendiquent la
paternité du homos donc et il est rentré
dans nos cuisines maintenant il faut
voir dans les supermarchés il est
partout tout le monde il fallait aller
vraiment rentrer dans un restaurant
libanais pour manger et maintenant il y
en a aussi trop confié au cumin aux pois
chiches bien sûr mais c'est bien que le
citron
un peu industrielle mais je trouve alors
sans parler d'homos industriel mais je
trouve intéressant qu'on est on
réussisse un peu à garder même beaucoup
à garder notre tradition culinaire
française
avec toute sa richesse et en même temps
de savoir emprunter tester goûter des
choses qui viennent d'ailleurs dans le
monde les fusion de Food aussi
parce que c'est de la découverte parce
que c'est du voyage moi j'aime beaucoup
voyager et parce que ça permet aussi de
montrer que la France est ouverte sur le
monde elle se regarde pas uniquement le
nombril et que elle s'enrichit des plats
des autres elle exporte ses propres
productions elle s'enrichit des plats
des autres et qu'on est dans une dans
une sorte d'échange je fais des bords
sur les questions politiques mais je
trouve que souvent on aurait intérêt à
un petit peu plus regardé ce qui se
passe en dehors de nos frontières déjà
ça nous permettrait d'être beaucoup plus
heureux en regardant nous-même notre
pays en disant quand même beaucoup de
chance d'être en France et ça permet
aussi d'avoir un esprit ouvert sur le
monde et je crois que c'est un peu
l'esprit français des lumières que de se
dire on n'est pas tout seul au monde
quoi il y a un esprit humaniste qui
dépasse nos frontières alors Jean-Pierre
leur rappelait au tout début vous êtes
né à Marseille
vous êtes dans l'OM et la bouillabaisse
alors seriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies fous ça la
soupe de poisson qui a donné la
bouillabaisse trouve son origine à
Syracuse en Sicile vrai ou faux
Syracuse en Sicile bénéfice du doute je
veux dire oui alors non en Grèce antique
son nom vient de l'expression provençale
bouée à Besseau qui signifie quand ça
bout il faut baisser d'accord vrai ou
faux je ne pourrais pas vous dire là je
est-ce que quand ça bout il faut baisser
ce que ça pourrait vouloir dire ça le
terme bouillabaisse ça me paraît pas
trop crédible mais je vais dire faux
mais c'est vrai
ça paraît complètement farfelu c'est
vrai dans son grand dictionnaire de la
cuisine Alexandre Dumas en sens la
bouillabaisse comme la soupe de poisson
la plus forte en goût vrai ou faux ça
peut être fort en goût
je dirais
oh là là je vais me faire des tester par
les Marseillais
dans la Charte de la bouillabaisse cette
soupe doit être servie dans un seul plat
qui contient le poisson qui nage dans le
bouillon vrai ou faux un seul plat avec
donc le poisson et le bouillon
c'est faux et c'est totalement
je dois rapidement retourner à Marseille
voir la famille et reprendre une
bouillabaisse
qui est le nouvel entraîneur de l'OM
c'est le la question on va arrêter le
quiz ça suffit non non pas ça
alors vous le savez sans doute Guillaume
casse barrière c'est souvent autour de
la table à l'occasion d'un déjeuner ou
d'un dîner que se fait la politique et
que les langues se délient c'est la
brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé de réfléchir à
un souvenir politique autour d'un repas
est-ce que vous avez une anecdote à nous
livrer
alors j'en aurais plein parce qu'à
chaque fois on partage beaucoup de
choses pendant les repas des ruers des
larmes des moments de joie des moments
de peine de grandes discussions
politiques des projets des idées donc en
fait il se passe toujours beaucoup de
choses à table
moi j'aime bien les fêtes du village
simple en fait et populaire et donc j'en
fais pas mal dans ma circonscription
parce qu'on a la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'activités grâce aux associations et
aux communes qui se bougent et donc moi
j'aime bien aller au fait du village et
j'aime bien passer derrière le comptoir
donc généralement ce qui se passe c'est
souvent on propose de passer derrière
pour se servir des saucisses ou servir
des frites ou servir la bière ou servir
la bière et donc généralement c'est là
où beaucoup de choses se passent en fait
puisque les gens viennent vous parler
parfois ils vous reconnaissent vous êtes
notre députés je suis là et ça permet
d'avoir des échanges assez libres et les
gens vous disent qu'il leur passe par la
tête assez simplement il y a des
messages assez naturellement et c'est à
la fois très plaisant parce que on se
fait plaisir on discute et on passe un
bon moment mais c'est aussi assez
instructif je trouve politiquement parce
que c'est les moments où les gens vous
font les retours qui leur état d'esprit
et ça vous permet quand vous reprenez la
semaine après à l'Assemblée nationale
d'avoir entendu deux trois choses sur
les fêtes du village qui vous donne
voilà deux trois éléments sur ce qui se
passe politiquement est-ce que les gens
ressentent actuellement c'est du concret
donc j'aurais tendance à dire que les
déjeuners les plus utiles d'un point de
vue politique sont probablement les
fêtes du village plus que les dîners de
salon ou les grandes messes ça on
apprend un peu moins de choses
d'habitude vous avez dit les gens vous
reconnaissent est-ce que c'est
je vais être venu avec d'ailleurs
j'avais tout le temps sur vous j'ai
souvent ma casquette il se trouve que
j'adore le fabriquer en France et il y a
une équipe qui a repris une vieille
chapellerie parce que là les gens
peut-être que vous pouvez la l'essayer
que les gens voient
la casquette c'est un peu la marque de
fabrique et c'est surtout aussi un
message sur le fabriqué en France donc
c'est une vieille chapellerie qui
s'appelait fléchés et fléchés étaient
déjà qui a été reprise et qui a été
remise au goût du jour et donc
l'entreprise produit des casquettes
fabriquées en France avec des tissus de
qualité et pour la promotion de manger
mais en tout cas ayant à l'esprit que
même sur le vestimentaire on a encore
des entrepreneurs des boîtes innovantes
qui essaient de faire du fabriquer en
France donc ça a commencé comme ça j'en
ai rapidement porté j'en ai un peu
toutes les couleurs chaque jour j'en ai
peut-être une de différentes et les gens
ils aiment reconnaît souvent avec la
casquette c'est vrai ça ou la moustache
ou les deux
ou le côté bonhomme je sais pas mais
mais en tout cas
ils ont repéré donc généralement quand
il me voit derrière le comptoir en train
de servir hier généralement il me
reconnaisse alors on va à présent parler
de la diversification dans l'agriculture
de plus en plus d'exploitations
fabriquent et vendent leurs produits sur
place c'est le dessous des plats
et Brigitte c'est justement l'histoire
d'une diversification réussie durement
touchée par les inondations de 2016 se
coupent de céréaliers a décidé de se
lancer aussi dans les pattes
alimentaires confectionnées avec leurs
propres blé dur Paris risqué mais plutôt
réussi c'est un reportage de Pierre
Michael Carniel et Marion de Vauchelles
[Musique]
donc là on va verser la farine de la
farine de l'eau et le tour est joué une
recette qui paraît simple mais dont
Jean-Philippe est assez fier puisqu'il
s'agit de sa propre production dans
cette ferme du Loiret 70% du blé est
vendu le reste est transformé en farine
dans un moulin avant de revenir à la
ferme pour la production de pâtes et si
cette exploitation céréalière s'est mise
en produit il y a quatre ans ce n'est
pas par hasard on a eu un un gros
accident climatique en 2016 et qui fait
que on a produit à peu près un tiers
d'une récolte classique donc d'une envie
de se diversifier c'est devenu un besoin
pour apporter d'apporter en fait de la
résilience en fait à la ferme et de
s'affranchir un petit peu des aléas en
fait des cours des céréales des aléas
climatiques ici la pâte est une affaire
de famille son épouse Sophie veille au
grain
donc après il a refaire le point sur les
expéditions
leur fils Léopold met aussi la main à la
pâte
emballé sur place les féculents
finissent leurs courses dans la boutique
juste à côté de l'atelier ici la
production est transformée dans tous les
sens la six formes différentes on a
certaines pâtes qu'on parfume avec des
épices ou des légumes on a aussi une
gamme de légumes secs qu'on cultive sur
la ferme récemment on a sorti une
boisson à base de sarrasin torréfié
c'est une infusion c'est une boisson
d'origine japonaise au départ et on s'en
est inspiré pour créer un sodaflet
faible en sucre des déclinaisons pour
augmenter les débouchés de leurs
produits fermiers si on travaille pour
20% en direct auprès des consommateurs
soit à la ferme ou sous forme de marché
ou de salon et puis après le reste c'est
auprès de professionnels
principalement des commerces de détails
métiers de bouche épicerie fine caviste
il maîtrise tout de l'épi à la
tortellini la fermet derrière le champ
est devant l'atelier est là donc
quasiment tout est fait et c'est ce qui
renforce un petit peu le l'idée de
produire en fait pour
sur son territoire pour des gens en fait
qui sont à proximité quoi au final on
nourrit 3000 personnes qu'elle soit
industrielle ou fermière les pâtes sont
appréciées des Français ils ont consommé
en moyenne 8 kg chaque année
alors est-ce que dans votre
circonscription vous assistez à ce genre
de diversification des des agriculteurs
des producteurs qui enquêtent sur
d'autres secteurs qui leur étaient ou
d'autres métiers qui leur étaient
méconnus jusqu'à lors oui c'est tout à
fait vrai on a des agriculteurs qui
travaillent la matière première les
céréales et qui ensuite derrière se
disent pourquoi pas faire la
transformation et essayer de monter des
produits à partir de ma matière première
je pense notamment à joui dans une
commune de matières conception il y a
une entreprise qui s'appelle les
joviettes et qui produit des pâtes
exactement sur ce qu'on vient de voir
c'est la même chose enfin au sens où il
a le même démarche de dire je produis
des pâtes locales à partir de ma
production et ça permet de développer
l'activité ça permet aussi d'aller
essayer de trouver de la valeur non pas
seulement que sur la matière première
mais aussi sur la transformation avec
notre département a toujours été sur la
matière première encore une fois les
grandes cultures les céréales on a eu
tendance ensuite à exporter ou à envoyer
ailleurs la matière première pour que
d'autres le transforment à notre place
sa vie pour un agriculture
gagnent mieux leur vie
économique qui fonctionne c'est des
entreprises les agriculteurs les
exploitations agricoles et donc comme
toutes les entreprises elles cherchent
des moyens de se diversifier d'essayer
de monter en amont ou en aval pour
essayer d'avoir un peu plus de valeur et
c'est de se dire comment est-ce que je
développe mon activité en amont on a sur
les pattes on peut la voir aussi sur la
bière
en Eure-et-Loir par exemple on a le
relieenne qui se développe très très
bien on a aussi des microbrasseries qui
se développent là encore souvent il y a
des agriculteurs derrière qui en réalité
on la matière première et ensuite essaie
de faire de la transformation et de
créer du marketing territorial autour
d'une marque locale qui marche bien soit
localement soit régionalement soit même
nationalement le relief par exemple
c'est-à-dire que ça permet de donner un
peu plus de résilience et de stabilité
parce que vous avez plusieurs lignes de
production ça vous permet aussi de
gagner de la valeur parce que ça vous
permet de détendre votre modèle
économique et ça vous permet
éventuellement de recruter des gens
d'avoir une activité qui marche mieux
encore une fois si on veut préserver
l'agriculture française et la développer
à l'avenir elle doit être intimement
liée à des questions public et
l'agriculture est une activité
économique donc il faut encourager les
agriculteurs quand cette volonté là faut
aussi l'encourager sur la commande
publique vous parliez des pâtes parfois
vous avez des agriculteurs qui décident
de se diversifier où ils se disent
niveau comment de public c'est un peu
léger vous commandez pas assez de patte
locale vous avez tendance à prendre le
moins cher et à prendre des pattes qui
sont parfois même pas produit de
localement un peu plus cher que celle
qu'on va trouver en Superman quelques
centimes de plus alors vous savez avec
artisanal on connaît avec la stabilité
avec Egalis transformation avec egalim
on a essayé de modifier un peu ce qui se
passait dans les cantines en mettant un
peu plus de local un peu plus de bio
pour en faire rentrer dans les cantines
le le local parfois il faut aussi que
des collectivités et elles le font
souvent mais il faut l'encourager
commande encore plus sur cet angle là
pour encourager les agriculteurs du
territoire qui produisent ici donc ça
c'est notamment quelque chose qu'on est
en train de travailler sur la commande
publique y compris sur le projet de loi
industrie verte qui arrive très bientôt
à l'Assemblée qu'on est en train
d'étudier mais il faut que la commande
publique est aussi joue son rôle et sur
la restauration collective il y a un
rôle à jouer pour encourager ses
agriculteurs qui se diversifient vous
vous êtes président de la commission des
affaires économiques et éclairez-nous
sur les prix dans l'alimentation parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'avec bon
effectivement la guerre en Ukraine les
prix du blé ont flambé donc on a vu très
très rapidement les étiquettes montées
on les voit baisser peut voir très peu
ou en tout cas moins sur des produits de
grande consommation des produits frais
des produits tous les jours est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire la réalité et
est-ce que vraiment on a atteint ce pic
de l'inflation ou pas alors en fait il
faut regarder le film global sur le la
question des prix et nous on l'a regardé
en commission éco en lançant un groupe
de suivi sur l'inflation donc ce qui a
expliqué au tout début l'augmentation
des prix agricoles c'est souvent la
matière première qui a augmenté pourquoi
parce que les agriculteurs y compris
pour les céréales faisaient face à une
envolée des prix sur le marché des
céréales en raison des aléas climatiques
dans certaines régions je pense au
Canada notamment mais aussi en raison de
l'augmentation du prix des intrants
c'est à dire des engrais et des produits
phytos qui sont des produits chimiques
qui parfois nécessitent beaucoup
d'énergie et donc en réalité étant donné
la crise énergétique qui a eu les
pour les agriculteurs sont devenus très
importants et les prix de des matières
premières agricoles ont vraiment
augmenté ces prix-là se sont répercutés
progressivement vous avez eu l'effet
répercuté
ça s'est répercuté sur les industriels
de l'agroalimentaire qui du coup là sur
les négociations commerciales avec la
grande distribution on négociait en
février de meilleurs prix pour dire nous
on subit la hausse des prix de l'énergie
pour notre transformation et notre
matière première école donc si vous nous
répercutez pas les prix sur le
consommateur nous on ferme en fait parce
qu'on n'arrivera pas à fonctionner donc
il y a eu des négociations commerciales
et en plus en France elles sont
annuelles c'est négociations
commerciales il faut qu'elle soit
terminée au 28 février et il faut
parfois un peu rééquilibrer les choses
parce que la grande distribution avait
tendance à mettre les prix vers le bas
et donc à mettre en difficulté des
producteurs donc il y a eu ces
négociations là qui ont eu lieu en
février et là du coup vous avez constaté
dans votre caddie une augmentation des
prix parce que les prix avaient augmenté
à ce moment-là mais il se trouve que
bien sûr bien évidemment mais encore une
fois si cette hausse n'avait pas eu lieu
et je comprends tout à fait d'ailleurs
qu'elle difficile pour beaucoup de
ménage bien sûr mais si ces prix-là
n'avaient pas augmenté vous mettiez à
terre tous les agriculteurs et toute la
filière industrielle française et vous
vous retrouviez avec du produit low cost
qui venait de l'étranger et sur lequel
ça marchait plus parce que derrière plus
14 % en mer donc c'est quand même après
vous avez eu la grande distribution qui
a joué son jeu en mettant en place un
panier anti-inflation à la demande de
Bruno Le Maire d'Olivier agrégoire sur
lesquels vous avez eu une sélection de
produits sur lesquels la grande
distribue a dit nous en Margera pas
alors ces produits là
mais si vous confiez vous le comparez à
d'autres pays européens vous vous rendez
compte qu'au final on n'est pas si mal
que ça par rapport à notre voisin faut
pas encore une fois regarder que
soi-même faut regarder ce qui se passe
dans les caddie de nos voisins allemands
espagnols italiens et regardez un petit
peu ce qui s'y passe bon là on arrive à
un point où les prix sont en train un
petit peu de baisser parce que la
tension sur le marché énergétique et pas
la même que l'hiver dernier donc on
commence à regagner un petit peu d'air
au niveau on espérait plus enfin le
consommateur espérait plus de
répercussions plus rapidement je suis
d'accord sauf que nous sommes dans un
cadre légal de négociation qui est
demandé par les acteurs annuels et
contrairement à d'autres pays où vous
n'avez pas ces négociations refusent de
rouvrir les négociations
dans la période qu'on vit actuellement
c'est que certains aujourd'hui disent
bah ça serait percute pas assez vite la
meilleure façon de le répercuter très
vite ça serait de dire que les
négociations sont permanentes et
qu'elles ne sont plus annuelles donc ça
par exemple il peut se passer dans
d'autres pays
qui visiblement dit ça se répercute pas
assez vite il faudrait aller plus vite
la meilleure façon de répercuter plus
vite c'est de dire on a un cadre de
négociation qui est plus le même
qu'aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr que tous
les acteurs en question est très envie
de sortir du cadre de négociation
actuelle entre grandes distributions
à entendre certaines interviews j'ai
sentiments que on a l'impression que
Leclerc est une ONG qui distribue
gratuitement de l'alimentation et fait
aucune marge etc donc moi je veux bien
mais en réalité ce sont des acteurs
économiques moi j'entends ce qu'ils
disent la de distribution les
industriels les agriculteurs on essaye
nous de faciliter les négociations vous
savez ce qui est impressionnant c'est
que dans d'autres pays européens les
négociations se passent bien mieux de
façon beaucoup plus apaisée entre la
grande distribution les fournisseurs en
France c'est très compliqué c'est très
agité c'est très rugueux avec des
acteurs qui aiment bien les médias et
qui aiment bien faire du punch mais en
réalité je suis pas sûr qu'au final le
consommateur s'y retrouve
le beurre l'argent du beurre parce qu'on
est à table on peut pas demander une
répercussion immédiate de toute
variation des prix et avoir un cadre de
négociation qui fait que les
négociations se passent une fois par an
si on veut en temps réel avoir une
répercussion totale des prix ça veut
dire que ça ça nécessite d'avoir une
ajustement de tous les acteurs à un
instant T et des négociations qui sont
beaucoup plus fines et ce qu'ils y sont
prêts et est-ce que c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils demandent j'en suis pas
totalement sûr mais on peut pas vouloir
dans les médias demander une
répercussion immédiate de des baisses et
en même temps regretter quand il y a des
périodes de hausse par exemple que on
soit obligé d'augmenter
qu'on essaie de leur dire c'est pas les
grands perdants les consommateurs qui
est une négociation une fois par an
c'est pas eux les grands perdants
finalement bah ça dépend si vous êtes à
la hausse ou à la baisse quand vous êtes
dans une période où les matières
premières augmentent et l'énergie
augmente le fait qu'il y ait une
négociation annuelle vous préserve de
l'inflation puisque vous n'avez pas une
répercussion immédiate de la hausse des
prix en revanche quand les prix baisses
mais du temps si vous avez pas une
négociation si vous avez une négociation
annuelle bah vous êtes obligé d'attendre
formellement la prochaine négociation
pour voir sur votre ticket de caisse les
prix baisser donc ce mécanisme là il
vous permet en fait de lisser un peu
plus l'inflation on vous préservant de
hausse comme des baisses il limite la
variation si on se dit on est prêt à
accepter la variation moi j'ai pas de
problème à se dire on négocie plus
régulièrement et on fait baisser les
prix mais il faut entendre derrière que
si on fait ça les périodes où il y aura
des hausse de prix de matière première
les répercussions seront aussi beaucoup
plus rapides or pendant la période qu'on
a observé il se trouve que la
répercussion de la hausse des prix a été
beaucoup plus faible que dans d'autres
voisins européens ou les caddie ont fait
plus 15 + 20 + 25 beaucoup plus
rapidement
les négociations restent annuelles enfin
les acteurs il a été demandé aux acteurs
de faire un geste de de faire des
baisses de prix en répercutant plus
rapidement le les baisses de coût sur
les prix de vente bon c'est ce qui a été
demandé sur la base du volontariat de la
bonne volonté des acteurs économiques
puisqu'on est dans une démocratie
libérale avec ou pas je pense qu'ils ont
pas intérêt non plus à afficher une à
dire NON NON rendez-vous au 28 février
prochain parce que si derrière les
consommateurs commencent à dire attendez
ils veulent pas baisser les prix alors
que leur coup baisse la sympathie qui
peut y avoir d'un point de vue grand
public pour les producteurs et pour les
industriels risque de baisser et les
gens commencent à dire vous êtes bien
gentil mais vous en mettez plein les
poches donc faudrait éviter d'arriver à
cette situation là c'est pour ça qu'il
est demandé de faire des efforts aux
acteurs industriels ils le font ils sont
en train de négocier ils sont en train
de voir comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
baisser moi j'ai bon espoir que cet été
on puisse avoir quelque chose de
raisonnable c'est-à-dire pourcentage je
pourrais pas vous dire c'est faut voir
que les acteurs font c'est à eux
d'expliquer d'ailleurs ce que pour
l'instant cette mesure en 0,1
d'expliquer ce qu'ils veulent faire je
dis juste attention parce que quand on
veut peu plus de variations quand on est
dans une tendance ou les prix baissent
très bien ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
accepter plus de variations quand les
prix montent et quand le législateur
fait la loi il l'a fait pas en réaction
à la hausse du mois dernier ou des deux
mois il fait la loi pour les années qui
viennent donc je voudrais être sûr que
si on bouge la loi on se retrouve pas
dans une situation où on a agi en
réaction très conjoncturelle d'une
variation et qu'on se met en difficulté
dans les années qui viennent quand on
fait la loi on le fait pour les
générations futures on le fait pas juste
pour nous-mêmes juste pour le
consommateur à un instant T à la semaine
près ou au jour près donc charge à nous
de garder un peu cette modération cet
équilibre en expliquant comme je viens
de le faire là les avantages et les
inconvénients d'avoir des négociations
annuelles on va à présent parler des
bras dans l'agriculture on en manque
alors pourquoi comment résoudre le
problème on en parle et on met les pieds
dans le plat
des cultures non ramassées mal
entretenues voire carrément abandonné
c'est la triste réalité dans certaines
exploitations françaises le problème un
manque de main d'oeuvre l'agriculture
est un métier qui peine à recruter comme
on peut le constater Jan menzina Thierry
Breton et Louise
on la récolte délicatement à la main une
par une asperge c'est l'une des cultures
qui demandent le plus de main d'oeuvre
dont cette exploitation du Barin 25
personnes sont en train de récolter mais
le chef d'exploitation annonce un autre
programme à son chef d'équipe à partir
de demain
elles ne seront pas ramassées plusieurs
parcelles qui resteront en terre
tu aurais pu continuer c'est dommage
parce que la demande elle est là le
marché il est toujours là mais bon on
est obligé d'arrêter la récolte qu'un
jour avant la fin
par manque de main d'oeuvre on n'a pas
assez de monde là 30 40 personnes en
plus
serrer les bienvenus très peu de
travailleurs locaux veulent venir car la
région est en quasi pleine emploi la
main devrait être en gère est elle aussi
plus compliquée à trouver une fois que
vous les trouvez vous avez le problème
du logement qui se pose actuellement
et là on est même en train de réfléchir
et de voir éventuellement pour reprendre
acheter un hôtel pour avoir une
indépendance et pour pouvoir héberger
nos notre personnels cette pénurie
conduit l'exploitation à renoncer à
certaines cultures
par celle de cornichon qui réclame
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre ne sera pas
agrandi à la place
pour ne pas laisser les parcelles vides
et c'est vrai qu'à l'avenir il faudra
qu'on fasse nos choix de culture en
fonction la main d'oeuvre qu'on a à
disposition des cultures perdu
es de main d'oeuvre pour s'occuper de
ses concombres ce plan aurait dû voir
ses feuilles coupées bien plus tôt la
plante n'a pas assez d'air pour respirer
et donc elle ne peut pas produire autant
de concombre qu'elles devraient le faire
en cette saison et malheureusement on
est obligé de se concentrer uniquement
sur la récolte au détriment mais de
l'entretien de nos plantes au quotidien
résultat 15% de rendement en moins pour
elle il y a une crise d'évocation
depuis on va dire la fin du covid
malheureusement nous on a de moins en
moins de personnes qui s'intéressent à
nos métiers manuels car il est classifié
dans les métiers très durs et très
compliqué de nombreux maraîchers
souhaitent voir prolonger les durées
légales pour employer des saisonniers
étrangers et compenser la pénurie de
recrutement
est-ce que ce problème de main d'oeuvre
vous y êtes confronté dans votre
circonscription c'est tout le territoire
pareil partout et pas qu'au niveau
agricole d'ailleurs toutes les
industries aujourd'hui ont du mal à
recruter les agriculteurs voulaient
montrer avec votre reportage donc je
veux bien sûr c'est une constante on a
aujourd'hui une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
on aura bientôt des centrales nucléaires
qu'on veut relancer avec de nouveaux EPR
il faudra recruter pour faire les
nouvelles centrales on a des mégas
usines qui vont arriver sur le
territoire on a parlé de Dunkerque on
pourrait parler d'autres méga usines de
batterie d'hydrogène sur lequel il va
falloir recruter massivement donc on a
des besoins de recrutement qui sont très
forts des besoins de main d'oeuvre qui
sont très forts la votre reportage il
est intéressant parce qu'il montre
plusieurs choses qui sont en lien avec
l'actualité y compris parlementaire
premier c'est la question de l'assurance
chômage que nous avons réformé à deux
reprises pour essayer de rendre le
travail attractif faire en sorte que le
travail paye et que le différentiel
entre le revenu du travail et le revenu
du chômage soit pas exactement le même
donc cette réforme là il faut la
poursuivre il faut peut-être l'amplifier
mais en tout cas c'est une première
pierre qui est de dire faire en sorte
que le travail paye soit plus attractif
que l'aide le deuxième
ce sujet c'est la question de la main
d'oeuvre étrangère vous l'avez vu dans
votre reportage vous avez des secteurs
qui semblent étrangères ne fonctionnent
pas c'est vrai pour certains saisonniers
on aurait pu parler des tomates chez
Philippe Vigier il y a une très belle
exploitation de tomates sous serre et
c'est des Ukrainiens qui aujourd'hui
travaillent dans cette serre c'est pas
des oriens c'est des Ukrainiens
l'agriculture partout les métiers en
tension vous en avez énormément mais
vous voyez bien qu'il y a une tension de
main d'oeuvre et quand on parle je fais
le lien avec l'actualité je pense que
vous le savez et vous le voyez bien
toutes les circonscriptions de France
vous avez des métiers que ce soit à
l'hôpital pour parler de l'hôpital de
Chartres ça soit l'agriculture que ce
soit l'industrie que ce soit certains
métiers en tension certains métiers de
service la restauration etc sur lequel
si vous n'avez pas de main d'oeuvre
étrangère et que demain vous coupez
complètement en disant bah il y a plus
personne qui rentre après vous nous
parlez du projet de loi immigration en
tout cas j'avais l'intention de
régulariser je pense que la question en
tout cas on peut pas dire je veux
absolument être soigné avoir un médecin
je veux aller au resto et je veux manger
des tomates françaises et en même temps
dire par contre je veux couper
complètement les la migration ça marche
pas aujourd'hui
qui est un sujet qui touche beaucoup les
saisonniers et les territoires intention
sur lesquels au-delà des questions de
recrutement ou de des questions de main
d'oeuvre disponible vous avez une
question il faut loger ces personnes là
et je pense que là on est dans une crise
du logement très forte le on a un
problème d'offre parce qu'on manque
d'offre de logement dans ces endroits-là
on a aussi une crise de demande à court
terme qui est venue avec des taux
d'intérêt qui ont fortement augmenté ces
derniers mois et qui bloquent un peu les
transactions donc on se retrouve dans
une tension sur le logement qui est
extrêmement forte et qu'il y a un
moindre je parle pas refaire le débat du
logement ici maintenant mais en tout cas
il y a des propositions qui ont été
faites par le gouvernement récemment on
a beaucoup de parlementaires qui sont
sur des propositions de loi et des
amendements au PLF prochain au budget
prochain qui arriveront en septembre qui
vise à débloquer la situation
c'est-à-dire développer débloquer la
crise de la demande à court terme
débloquer la question de l'offre à long
terme dans les territoires qui recrutent
à fond les ballons territoire agricole
territoire industriel territoire
énergétique on met des centrales sur il
va falloir construire à fond parce que
là il s'agit de réconcilier notre
ambition industrielle de souveraineté de
relocalisation et la question du
logement qui est absolument acheter des
immeubles acheter pour nos g finalement
vos salariés
un rapport en commission écho sur le
sujet justement du lien entre emploi et
logement il y a Dominique Da Silva qui
travaille également sur une proposition
de loi mais on a des parlementaires qui
aujourd'hui disent on ne peut pas avoir
des territoires en tension avec du
touristique de l'industriel de
l'économie et derrière pas de solution
de logement pour les habitants et les
travailleurs qui veulent s'y loger et
donc ce lien là entre emploi et logement
doit être fort et vous avez raison de
dire qu'il faut inciter les employeurs
peut-être à investir dans le logement et
bien sûr mais c'est peut-être l'état
aussi peut mettre un coup de pouce pour
aider
exactement c'est qu'on est dans un
problème de blocage aujourd'hui avec des
taux qu'on vachement augmenté un petit
peu en tout cas ce qui est sûr si on
fait rien si on fait rien et que on se
dit bah on laisse le marché faire
et on se dit bah tant pis il y aura un
problème bon vous allez avoir un
problème de demande à court terme qui
fait que on va avoir un effondrement
encore plus fort de la construction et
du coup des plans sociaux dans le
domaine de la construction vous risquez
d'avoir après un problème avec vos
industriels qui se sont installés sur le
territoire ou vos agriculteurs qui se
sont installés sur le territoire et qui
disent mais c'est bien gentil mais
j'arrive pas à recruter et j'arrive pas
à les loger et ils peuvent pas être là
et donc vous trouvez avec un premier
économique profond parce que le logement
est un sujet économique profond c'est
pas pour rien qu'on étudie en commission
des affaires économiques sur le sujet
donc vous voyez que ce que vous évoquez
à travers votre reportage sur la
question agricole avec la tension qu'on
a sur la main d'oeuvre évoque des sujets
politiques nationaux qui sont
extrêmement forts aujourd'hui sur la
question de l'assurance chômage sur la
question de l'immigration de travail et
les travailleurs dont on a besoin dans
certains secteurs qui ne peuvent pas
fonctionner autrement aujourd'hui et sur
la question plus profonde du logement
qui est une condition de la
réindustrialisation et de la
relocalisation sur le territoire j'ai
une question pourquoi votre avis comment
faut rendre ces métiers attractifs
pourquoi la main d'oeuvre nationale ne
vient pas vers ces métiers alors je
pense qu'il peut y avoir
alors dans certains cas ça peut être un
défaut de qualifications est-ce qu'il
faut augmenter les taux c'est vrai qu'il
y a certains métiers qui n'étaient pas
attractifs et qui ont fait un gros
travail de remise en question pour
augmenter la tractivité auprès des
candidats salariés bon ça passe par la
restauration par exemple
agriculture je suis dans l'extension de
l'agriculture mais cela dit sur les
table donc dans la restauration on est à
table dans la restauration il y a eu un
effort qui a été fait pour rendre plus
attractif
bien sûr mais parce que derrière il y
avait une question de comment est-ce
qu'on rétractif les choses de son côté
l'État lui essaye de se dire on a une
assurance chômage qui est un peu plus
flexible sur lesquelles quand on est
dans des périodes un peu de tension
comme on le voit actuellement on a
peut-être pas la même générosité que
l'on peut avoir en temps normal et on
peut se dire que il faut inciter
les gens à saisir les offres d'emploi
qui sont sur le territoire il y avait un
déplacement du président de la
République à Marseille qui était plus
appelé sur le sujet vous parlez de
Marseille
le président de la République dit une
réalité que tous les Français perçoivent
bien et que vous montrez bien dans votre
reportage qui est de se dire il y a des
offres d'emploi un peu partout et il se
trouve que on a des personnes qui disent
je veux chercher du boulot je veux avoir
un boulot mais parfait nous avons
aujourd'hui des employeurs qui
n'attendent que ça et donc quand il l'a
dit à Marseille non seulement j'étais
pas choqué mais je trouvais que c'était
tout à fait vrai et réaliste la preuve
c'est que la Provence est allée sur le
Vieux-Port et en 1h30 ils ont regardé
les offres ils ont dit il y a 13 offres
au SMIC 35 heures payées 2000 euros sur
lequel vous allez des autres très offres
disponibles en une heure et demie donc
preuve en est que nous sommes bien dans
cette réalité là et qu'il faut du coup
encourager à mieux mettre en relation
l'offre qui est bien là et les
demandeurs d'emploi qui sont encore là
et sur lesquels il faut inciter à
prendre ces boulots après que l'État
fasse son boulot soit la formation les
compétences etc bien sûr et parfois il
peut y avoir des métiers il faut être
qualifié il faut être compétent et donc
là il faut jouer le jeu que certains
secteurs aient besoin d'augmenter les
salaires pour se rendre attractif c'est
tout à fait vrai aussi mais force est de
constater vous l'avez montré qu'il y a
des offres d'emploi sur le territoire et
des entrepreneurs des entreprises qui
n'attendent que ça que de recruter donc
il faut mettre les gens en relation
on a fini on va passer au dessert à
présent et c'est le péché mignon
et pour le coup Brigitte on a connu des
convives plus gourmands que notre invité
du jour aujourd'hui pas de débauche
dessus de crème fraîchement anglaise de
nappage au chocolat ou au caramel que
sais-je non juste des fruits et encore
pas n'importe quel fruit puisqu'ils
doivent être français et de saison pour
ne pas se faire taper sur les doigts
alors voici une petite salade avec des
abricots des fraises et des framboises
après un aligot c'est le must pour bien
digérer le fromage déjà vous voyez quand
ça faire chaud dans la pièce parce
qu'après un aligot faut quand même
quelque chose d'un peu léger peut-être
pour la suite donc on n'est pas passé
par la case fromages et on passe
directement au dessert et avec les
fruits frais de saison déjà c'est léger
c'est bon les fruits c'est bon aussi
pour la santé il faut le rappeler un
intérêt sanitaire et puis le fait de
d'avoir des fruits de saison français
fabriquer localement c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut encourager et qui ont été
ramasser ceci mettez ramassé on a la
chance d'avoir des producteurs de fruits
et légumes français vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui les deux tiers des fruits
que vous consommez sont fabriqués à
l'étranger et donc et cette tendance là
elle n'a pas tendance à diminuer donc
moi je je passe je profite de l'émission
pour passer un message manger des fruits
et légumes et manger des fruits et
légumes de saison de saison et français
n'allait pas acheter hors saison des
choses qui sont produites à des milliers
de kilomètres sous serre dans de
mauvaises conditions n'allez pas pour la
planète c'est pas bon pour la planète
c'est pas bon du tout donc prenez des
fruits qui sont dans vos territoires et
un partout en ce moment c'est la bonne
période pour pouvoir justement manger
plein c'est pas le fruit quand même les
fraises tout ça les framboises quand on
regarde le prix des barquettes c'est pas
c'est pas donné en plus d'ailleurs on
pourrait revenir on pourrait revenir on
pourrait refaire la discussion sur les
contraintes qu'on a mis aux agriculteurs
et qui sont que ça a baissé la
production les cerises sont un
merveilleux exemple de secteurs sur
lequel on a mis des on a mis des
contraintes voilà on a mis des
contraintes à des agriculteurs ils
disent bah pardon mais du coup il y en a
moins c'est plus cher et après on dit
c'est cher dans le caddie bah c'est cher
dans le caddie pourquoi parce qu'il y a
eu derrière des décisions qui ont été
prises donc là encore soyons cohérents
on peut pas vouloir une alimentation à
la fois de qualité fraîches de saison
française et en même temps dire derrière
on leur met des contraintes et on les
empêche de produire donc on revient sur
notre débat de tout à l'heure moi ce que
je veux juste te dire c'est va profiter
de la saison et c'est la belle saison
pour le faire tous l'été pour manger des
fruits et légumes français ça pousse
chez nous ça pousse à côté de chez vous
c'est des producteurs locaux profitez-en
et éviter l'hiver de faire venir de trop
trop loin des fruits et légumes qui sont
produits
mais j'adore les fruits et légumes
j'aime beaucoup la viande et ça
m'empêche pas d'aimer beaucoup les
fruits et des légumes et bien sûr je
profite de votre émission pour passer ce
message là parce que la filière fruits
et légumes c'est aussi une fierté
culinaire française et qu'il faut
l'encourager dans une période difficile
de tension sur le recrutement de parfois
de contraintes qui leur sont mises et de
concurrence avec l'international qui est
très forte et donc encourageant les
producteurs de fruits et légumes
français votre fruit préféré c'est
lequel on les fruits rouges
j'adore les fruits rouges en fait les
fraises les framboises j'en ai un peu
dans le jardin les groseilles j'aime
bien d'ailleurs ça pousse en ce moment
dans mon jardin fraise framboise
groseilles c'est ce que j'ai dans mon
jardin et ça marche j'aime bien les
fruits rouges
et alors là on se retrouve avec des
fleurs
mais cela dit vous faites ça après un
aligot aussi je pense que là on dort
toute l'après-midi on fait la sieste
donc je me suis dit on va être
raisonnable parce qu'on a quand même du
boulot cet aprèm et donc on va passer
aux fruits c'est très bon aussi mais la
prochaine fois on fera du du par lava et
du Moral habillé
vous reviendrez et on casse barrière
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
c'était la dernière émission de
politique à table pour cette saison
rassurez-vous on revient à la rentrée et
vous allez pouvoir nous suivre aussi
tous les thés à très bientôt sur LCP